sweats we all sweat right then it sucks
but it's actually not that bad because
it's our body's way its natural way of
helping us to cool down whenever we're
overheating but it becomes a problem
when we sweat too much and we feel
uncomfortable in many situations so in
this video I'm gonna give you six tips
to stop sweating so much let's get right
into the video hey guys I'm Daniel and
welcome here on my channel if you're new
subscribe click the notification bell
and then you won't miss any of the next
videos now let's start with the first
step to sweat less you gotta eat less
spicy food why
well spicy food can activate your brains
neurotransmitters making you sweat more
consume less caffeine things like coffee
tea can make you sweat a lot more
caffeine stimulates your central nervous
system and activates your sweat lines so
the more caffeine you drink the more
you'll sweat and also when it's hot it
doesn't help either it makes you sweat
even more
you gotta stop using deodorant why well
deodorant itself it just helps you not
to smell you know but it doesn't stop
the sweat you gotta use a antiperspirant
antiperspirant helps you to sweat less
and it also helps you not to sting a lot
a few good options for interview
description that you can check out
change the clothes that you wear get
closed with cool and breathable material
like linen and cotton
there are also workout clothes that you
can get that absorbs the sweat and will
help you out if you sweat a lot more
than other people you might have
hyperhidrosis that is six people with
excessive sweating now there's a few
tips few options that treatments that
you can do but it's better to go and see
your doctor but some of those treatments
include oral medications that block
chemicals that allow certain nerves to
communicate to each other helping you to
sweat less but there might be a few side
effects so speak to your doctor you can
also try Botox injections that
temporarily block the nerves that cause
you to sweat but it only lasts around
six to twelve months you can also try
surgery but this is only in extreme
cases surgery options include microwave
therapy sweat gland removal and nerve
surgery
anxiety also cause excess sweating so
what helps for this well you can try
antidepressants but I wouldn't suggest
going on antidepressants too quick I
think psychologists and doctors they
give it out too quickly and too easily
and people become dependent on it so
find other ways to do it for anxiety
instead and remember anxiety happens
when you think that you have to figure
out everything at the same time breathe
take a step back look at the situation
from another perspective breathe take it
day-by-day
you've got this if you liked the video
give it a thumbs up subscribe and I'll
see you in the next video Cheers
[Music]